d'abord alors on a on a un souffleur à
la table on est en ce2 mieux cgc jean
pascal
vous êtes soffer j'ai commencé et saufs
ils étaient sauveteurs en mer bah oui
bah d'aller sauver déclic
il a sauvé des vies ben voilà et quand
cela tient bien sûr mais il ya un set
fut le père dirige d'alerté à malibu non
moi c'était plus arrête le malibu ce ne
l'était mais c'est consommer avec
modération en médiation
les gens pourraient avant d'être pompier
j'ai sauvé la vie à trois enfants mais
j'ai été décoré de le courage et
dévouement et leur look la rente et qui
vous intéressait c'était pour la star
qu'on vous intéresse sur la plage sur la
plage pendant que j'étais pompier sur la
dernière année ah ouais ouais bon c'est
fait toujours plaisir après ce n'est pas
le sien d'abord ils ont écarté toutes
les conneries qu'il veut essayer en
observant que chevrier puis après voilà
vous parce que pas parenthèse on doit
oui dans les relations qui nous fait
devient flou mais on est on a connu en
tout début d'été rac dans le testing il
se foutait éperdument de savoir si vous
aimez chanter ou par leur histoire
mais évidemment pas gta pour [ __ ] pas
façon que même après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
3 984 cervelle de la musique mesdames si
vous avez un problème on a un sauveteur
est cet homme qui portait pas ses coûts